Kim Kardashian spotted for the first  time since her traumatizing robbery in  Paris here's the reality star remaining  incognito after her scary heist wearing  a hooded sweatshirt and shorts as she  stepped out to grab a bite to eat with a  girlfriend in Beverly Hills Thursday  night and eye witness tells et Kimmie  appeared very downcast and somber while  grabbing takeout and she wasn't with her  usual safety squad quote she was with  security and it wasn't pesco her main  bodyguard but it was really tough for me  a source told et previously Kim is still  very shaken up over being robbed at  gunpoint  and tied up earlier this month and her  actions speak louder as kardashian  remained silent online only making a  quiet return to social media by going on  an unfollowing spree on twitter so when  will Kim recover and return to work on  her reality show we'll just have to wait  and see  you